toucher les livres les feuilleter et
découvrir les nouveautés pour faire son
stock avant les vacances c'est de
nouveau possible dans les médiathèques
de saint quentin en yvelines
le site aimé césaire à la verrière est
ouvert les mardis et vendredis de 15h à
18h je m'en attendais quand même de
pouvoir renouveler le stock qu'ils en
ont pu bien utilisé et consulté pendant
la période de confinement donc on a eu
des appels quand même des adhérents ping
qui attendaient avec hâte et dès le
premier jour de réouverture mardi 7
juillet les adhérents étaient présents
heureux de pouvoir se plonger dans de
nouvelles histoires
j'ai essayé chercher dans les vieux
livres de mes parents mais après c'était
quand même moins bien que de trouver des
livres qui ne correspondaient quoi la
1ère fois je suis venu c'est en mars
2020 mes petits enfants
je leur prends régulièrement des livres
donc j'attendais un petit peu fait
deauville la biotech et regarder
régulièrement sous le site quand est-ce
que ça va ouvrir pouvoir rentrer dans la
médiathèque
toucher les livres regarder les
nouveautés ça nous manquait beaucoup
quoi naturellement l'espace a été adapté
pour accueillir le public dans de bonnes
conditions sanitaires du gel hydro
alcoolique est à disposition et les
salles de travail et espace bébés ne
sont pas encore accessibles
on ne peut venir quand on veut pour
rendre et emprunter des documents
on peut de nouveau faire des
réservations sur tout le réseau comme on
faisait avant par contre effectivement
il faut porter un masque à partir de 12
ans la médiathèque aimé césaire restera
exceptionnellement ouverte tout l'été
de quoi s'évader même en restant à la
maison